hello everyone for everyone out there
who thought that Vichy is too old or you
know that he really should retire from
professional chess Anand has a message
for everyone and that message is I am
still king after 15 rounds of the world
rapid championship Anand and Nepal
Miyagi and fed of save here were tied in
first place with 10 and a half points
since I made the very precise and
calculated decision to make a quick
drawing around 15 saying to Coulson if
you want to win the World Championship
you have to beat the district and that's
not an easy task especially in the last
round of any championship so I made a
quick drawing around 15 and here after
15 rounds there was a tie break uh
non-faces Vladimir federal save and out
of the two games they played Anand won
both games and this is the one game
where Anand has the black pieces and
it's it's quite a bloodbath so so let's
see this game and the ending is kind of
confusing to me I didn't get a chance to
catch the live feed so probably some of
you have seen it and you will know what
happened there
federal save opens with Knight to f3 the
reti opening Allen goes d5 mmm
we have g3 Knight to f6 and Bishop to g2
the Kings Indian attack
we have c5 feather save castles and
Knight to c6 c4 d4 and III will be 5 e
capture some d 4e captures on d4 and d3
Bishop to e7 hundred prepares to castle
Bishop to f4 on castles and rook to e1
knife to h5 attacking the bishop on f4
Bishop back to C 1 and we have nice to
f6 back by Anand knife to a3 a 6 and we
have Knight to e5 Knight captures rook
captures and Bishop to d6 kicking the
rope back rook to e1 and outcomes rook
to b8 nice to see - we have h6 and b4
and it seems like you could capture this
pawn it looks like a free pawn but if
you capture then simply Queen to d2
there's gonna be I mean a white can
easily retrieve
spawn if you even try to protect it
again then Bishop to b2 there's a double
attack on the d4 point so there is no
way to actually win material here you're
just gonna worsen your position
so after before I don't place b6 we have
built be captures on c5 be captures on
c5 and now be sure to a3 as there really
is no good square to develop this dark
square Bishop e3 is taken F Forest
impossible g5 is impossible so a3 seems
like a reasonable decision
Anna plays Queen to a5 we have Queen to
c1 now protecting the bishop on a3 so
now the night and c2 could move but in
reality it doesn't really have a place
to move Rupp to d8 by Anand and now
comes I mean white is really what is
really I mean it's not a it's not that
black is actually in it so much better
position but it's hard for white to play
any move so here if federal save tries a
very nice tactic I mean it's a it's a
sneaky tactic and this is where the
bloodbath really starts knife captures
on d4 my fellow save here
Anand please see captures on d4 with a
bishop captures on d6
rook captures and Queen to f4 now
attacking the rook on d6 if that rook
moves the other look on NB 8 will be
hanging and here on unplayed Queen to c7
Queen to c5 was a better choice but you
have to find it after rook to e5
attacking the Queen the Queen can
actually come to a 3 and that
disposition will be okay for for black
but on plays Queen to c7 and it's I mean
it's just as well
c5 here Quintus e5 would actually
prevent this annoying let's call it
tactic and the best move here is
actually to capture this pawn but again
you have to find that after Queen
captures rook comes to see one or rook a
comes to c1 that after Queen before you
can't really continue harassing the
Queen if you play will be one simply
mean captures rook can be one and after
rook captures rook captures the King has
nowhere to go you have to block this
with Bishop to f1 and now comes Bishop
to h3 there is no defense against rook
captures an F
and black one yes so after c5 unplayed
rook to d7 and now this really allows
the annoying tactic of c6 this comes
with an attack on the rook if you move
the rook your queen is hanging if you
move this the Queen the rook and b8
could be hanging so the best idea here
is to actually play rook to d6 and again
everything is fine for black but Anand
plays Queen captures on f4 and he allows
the annoying in-between move C captures
on b7 and now your queen is still
attacked on f4 fate of service
threatening d8 to promote the pawn to a
queen
Anand stops this Queen to c7 and we have
rook to e8 check now if you capture the
rook then D captures will grab the night
and also bring up another Queen so King
to h7 was played and now d8 Queen but
fortunately for Anand that there is this
Knight captures on e8 that is actually
protecting the Queen and c7 so Queen
captures on e8 and we have Bishop to f5
now on and immediately jumps into the
attack going for the d3 point and it's
very rare that you will see after a
bloodbath like this that the material on
the board is completely equal Queen to a
for attacking the d4 pawn and we have
Queen to c3 making more pressure to the
d3 pawn also this comes with a temple on
the rook on a1 RUP to d1 by feather sev
and now Bishop captures on d3 a nun
grabs upon also now the pawn on a6 is
protected by the bishop so everything is
well and the vichy is up a pawn h4 by
Faris if he has to try and make
something happen but rook to be one as
Anand is up upon you he wants to
exchange more material rook captures
Bishop captures and we have Queen to e8
going for the f7 pawn on and simply
defense this Bishop to g6 and here comes
the Bishop to d5 attacking the f7 pawn
but Anand sees that his deep deep one is
actually marching down the board d3 is
played here we have Bishop captures on
f7 Bishop captures on f7 Queen captures
on f7
and since I didn't catch the live feed I
don't exactly know what happened here in
this position on unplayed 21 check and
after King to g2 he pushed the d2 and in
this position it seems that Vladimir
feathers have resigned the game as I saw
under 1 this game but actually I mean
after Queen to f5 there really is no way
to prevent perpetual check for example
Queen Queen queen f5 in King g8 Queen to
c8 and what do you play here if you play
King King to f7 how can you how can you
prevent the perpetual check Quincy four
check the King can come ok perhaps the
king will be able to escape yeah
it seems the king will be able to escape
but I thought yeah ok I thought after
Queen that Queen to f5 was actually good
enough to make a perpetual check but ok
after this D to move Vladimir pharisee
resigned the game obviously this isn't
enough for white to gain a perpetual but
it wouldn't be enough since Anand
already won one game so if this is the
case for those of you who have seen the
live feed do share in the comments and
once again congratulations to wish
Manhattan Island for winning the world
rapids championship Fetisov here got
second place and the end upon me ah she
is third Magnus Carlsen after all the
drama in round 15 got fifth place in the
end and interestingly Peter Svidler who
won the Russian chess championship I
think it was like ten days ago also
broke into the top ten players you know
regarding the de l'eau rating and now he
won't 10th place in the world rabbit
championship so you know I don't think
we've seen the last of Peter sweedler
but yeah that was the game Anand is the
world champion in rapid chess and it
seems like you know he still has it
maybe he maybe he can't really take it
you know how do I say it
maybe it's the heart for
to play classical games since I mean he
is older so maybe maybe that's too
exhausting for him but here in rapid
chess I mean he totally destroyed all
the young players and you know I really
really wanted like a pro so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here both of them will be from
the world rapid championship in the
description below there will be a link
to my playlist containing all of the
games I made for the world rapid
championship you feel free to check
those out thank y'all for watching and I
will see you soon probably tomorrow with
some more games from the world rapper
championship and the world blitz
championship it is starting so sometimes
some nice games from there will be
analyzed and uploaded as well thank you
all and I will see you soon